how long were you on the road for before
you get an audition for Saturday Night
Live is that your big break Saturday
Night Live sure I did a HBO young
comedian special hosted by Dennis Miller
he was the anchor guy there he was the
news guy did he recommend Lauren listen
to you yeah okay so Rob Schneider was on
with me me and Rob got an audition for
SNL and we go like catch Rising Star
I've never been to New York really and
I'm like there's 20 people there Lauren
Dennis a couple writers and I do my I'm
supposed to do 20 minutes I do 12 and
get off because I'm [__] the bed so
bad uh Schneider does 12. Schneider's
got a funny act he and he and he was
like no chance wow yeah Tom Kenny who
does the voice of SpongeBob you might
know he killed he did all 20 minutes he
killed me and Rob get hired why did you
ever ask Lauren why yeah he said it was
the writing the writing because I like
the way you guys wrote the way you
thought it was out of the movie it was
just a little dry a little weirder for
the show you know did you do Impressions
I did Michael J fox hey Sarge You Gotta
Give me a little time on this
oh Christ Mallory well you just smell
your finger when you do it yeah listen
is that what I'm doing he would touch
his face
I get on SNL and they want me to write
for everyone and that's always hard I
don't want to do that I don't know how I
don't know how to write a sketch right
and no one's there coaching you everyone
just slams the door by the way it was a
tough time because you write your own
sketches or did you work on a team I did
but they go I'd rather you write for
Dana Carvey and Mike Myers and everyone
I'm like well [__] I don't I don't want
to know what their moves are I don't
know how to write that they're too good
for me I they write for themselves
yeah they already had a Dana which is a
better version of me right so if an
impression looked like Sandler he did it
if it looked like Rob he did if it
looked like me Dana did it what was the
first sketch you ever wrote that
actually got on the air Michael J fox
was the host I was gonna do an
impression of him that was the only
thing I had in my bag so everything was
Michael J fox and that was my one thing
and they go and and Lauren goes hey uh
Michael J fox is next week I'm like I
know I saw it on the board I'm all
excited I get to do one [__] movie is
can you teach Dana how to do that
impression
you're [__] kidding oh my God so I
teach Dana he does it in the monologue
and then I come out third they threw me
a crumb let me come out as third guy
meanwhile it looks like I'm copying Dana
and then you know Sandler Blows By Me in
a rocket ship Farley's a huge star
Schneider's doing copy machine were you
ready to like kill yourself it was very
stressful because people from Arizona
would call and go dude I stayed up right
even on that show that makes it worse of
course they're loving that I'm [__]
you know they're like so so did you
think they were gonna fire you I'm like
an NFL quarterback on the bench like you
were good in college and then like
they're not playing you know would you
ever go to Lauren and like how am I
going to get started but you can't do
that right you can't be like a
complainer yeah I'm like is there
anything unzip I can do
um
but so what do you so what do you so so
David what was the Breakthrough for you
I mean I never even got over I think I
just always was okay on the show I did I
did a Hollywood minute I did this one
thing when I was a receptionist I wrote
where I'm like and you are and this is
regarding and it was sort of an attitude
piece which I didn't think would do good
that did well I still remember so I go
that was the first time like these
aren't even real jokes this is just like
an attitude yeah and I go that's funny
how did you learn how to write a script
if you don't know how to write a script
my first sketch is like 18 pages on I
don't know I don't know and they go you
have five sets in here I go what the
[__] does that mean they go you should
have two and we just do them over here
and you got to see how expensive they
are and I go oh no one they they want
you to go fired they don't want you
there so everyone just slams their door
and even Schneider's like later what a
life and they're all my buddies and the
hard thing was not to get super jealous
I mean obviously I got jealous because
I'm human and I was the longest feature
player everyone moved up that started
with me you know so Sandler and
Schneider and all those guys were all
comedians working with you in clubs and
all these guys now on TV you're there
with them but you're like not noticed
yeah and I'm going the road and they
would even it would even get humiliating
we're like you should come with Sandler
you Schneider Sandler we do that for a
while and then I'd hear Stanley gets
more right and it's that thing that the
only thing that's kept me alive in the
career is
not freaking out at that
foreign